si hoy entra en vigor este el límite al
precio del petróleo ruso en que la Unión
Europea de los países del g7 pactaron
poner un límite a de 60 dólares al
barril solo es una es una medida que
básicamente afecta al transporte por las
navieras europeas que ya tendrán
prohibido poder transportar este
petróleo ruso a terceros países es decir
fuera del g7 y de la Unión Europea a un
límite máximo de 60 dólares Si un país
tercero paga a un precio mayor las
navieras europeas van a tener que
negarse y no podrán transportar este
petróleo hay que recordar que las
navieras europeas tienen un importante
cuota de Mercado sobre todo las griegas
y las chipotletas lo que se espera que
pueda afectar gravemente a las compañías
europeas aún así como comentabas Raúl
esta medida de hecho apenas afecta la
Unión Europea porque a partir de hoy
tiene prohibida la importación Por barco
de todo el petróleo ruso ya la Unión
Europea no va a comprar más petróleo
ruso Así que lo que es sobre todo afecta
sobre todo ese este transporte a
terceros países en cualquier caso de
momento el petróleo de barril de brent
que es el de referencia aquí en Europa
está cotizando de momento al alza sigue
manteniéndose también la producción tal
y como anunció la OPEP también este
pasado fin de semana aún así todo el
mundo está perdiendo está pendiente de
la cotización del petróleo también en
clave económica hay que tener en cuenta
que hoy Bruselas está muy pendiente de
una reunión de alto nivel entre la
comisión Europea y la Casa Blanca debido
a la ley de reducción de la inflación
que la Unión Europea conseguirá muy
discriminatoria de momento va a haber
esta reunión para intentar bajar la
tensión entre Washington y bru